This is very exciting news
and a little bit of a surprise.
We have an exclusive Broadway preview tonight
that we're gonna show you.
(audience cheers)
Yeah.
It's a musical.
It's a musical about the life of the patriot
Samuel Adams.
Critics are already calling it, quote,
"Another musical about a founding father."
(audience laughs)
Here to perform a selection,
this is so exciting.
Please welcome the cast of Adams.
(audience applauds)
Wait, wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
(audience laughs)
Stop the music.
I know history pretty well.
Sam Adams didn't invent beer.
(audience laughs)
Okay, we lied about that part, yeah,
but the rest of the show is true.
Conan, are you sure that this
is a Broadway preview,
I mean, this seems like it could be
one of those paid product integrations
by the Sam Adams beer people.
(audience laughs)
No, no, no, this is not a commercial
because ...
(audience laughs)
Not cool.